Speaker 1: We appear to be approaching potentially
two more arrests of failed former President Donald
Trump. First and foremost is that Fannie
Willis in Georgia is stepping up security and
precautions for this next season, so to speak, of
announcing indictments that will start in July and
run through September. There is the belief that
Trump is getting indicted there. But separately,
there is a Rolling Stone article. Trump's lawyers
warn him, get ready to be indicted by the feds.
The former president has angrily complained
in response to predictions that if the Justice
Department is going to charge him, then what
about Joe Biden? What about Joe Biden? And the
article says Some of Trump's lawyers and advisers
have given the former president an unwelcome,
if not unexpected message in recent weeks. You
should expect to get indicted this year. Now,
we've talked before about the seemingly un derail
the bill train that is Trump speeding towards the
Republican nomination. And in those hypotheticals,
the question about what could derail it
has mostly gone to if Trump gets arrested and is
so bogged down by criminal cases that he quite
literally can't get out on the campaign trail
in any substantive way, it starts to affect
the Republican electorate and people who currently
say they would be voting for Trump in the primary
were it today. Move on to someone else, maybe
DeSantis or maybe someone else. But short of that,
Trump seems to have an unobstructed path to the
nomination. And yet we now seem to be potentially
within months of Trump getting arrested two
more times. The article also says several legal
and political counselors to Trump have bluntly
informed him they expect the Justice Department
to charge him in the criminal investigation
into his hording of highly classified documents
following the end of his presidency. Two sources
familiar with the matter tell Rolling Stone.
This, of course, comes on the heels of Trump's
indictment by local prosecutors in Manhattan in
April for falsifying business records. Later this
summer, officials in Fulton County, Georgia, are
expected to make a decision about whether or not
to indict Trump. Trump's attorneys and confidants
told Trump that though they view the federal
investigation as B.S., they would be surprised
at this point if he wasn't charged, particularly
for alleged obstruction of justice, and have
urged Trump to prepare for yet another historic
fight. Looks like they're going for it. One of the
sources says people close to the former president
have discussed with him what we think is going to
happen soon and how he and everyone else needs
to be ready for it. It would be crazy not to. So
there's two things going on here. One, there are
very real political implications. We are quickly
getting into the heat of a very hotly contested
Republican primary. It will be an unprecedented
situation where the current president will be
running for reelection. That's Joe Biden against
a former president. Who was already defeated by
Biden and then will be running again against him.
Unprecedented. And you throw into the middle of
that already one, maybe two, maybe a third arrest,
and it is going to be complete and total chaos
if we go beyond the political implications.
Progress is slow, but we are seeing some progress.
Now, I still don't believe that we are going
to see Trump do a day of prison or jail. I don't
think we're going to see it in any of these cases.
However, if you look at the degree to which
this has gone from, this stuff should be
investigated to there are investigations
to we're talking to a grand jury to. It's
looking like the grand jury wants to convict.
Trump has been arrested once and maybe and may
end up arrested three times. That is major
progress in seeking to find justice for the
alleged wrongs of the Trump presidency. So we
will be following the forthcoming possibility
of more arrests very closely. It is important to
also understand that while Trump seems to have
an unobstructed path to the nomination, unless
multiple arrests take him off the campaign trail,
the so called anti-Trump Republican movement
seems to be imploding. Let's talk about that next.